today kids we're going to be comparing
Jesus to Muhammad peace view so one of
the most controversial videos that I've
ever done would have to be the Quran
challenge if you click the link you'll
get to see the thousands of threats that
I received for insinuating that the
Quran wasn't inherently a peaceful book
now many people think it's very unfair
to compare the acts of Christians to the
acts of Muslims and I still agree both
groups often consist of hypocrites so
let's get to the root of the issue yes
let's look to the faiths holiest of
prophets their model citizens if you
will
Jesus versus Muhammad
[Music]
[Applause]
also quick note even though I know that
I can physically portray Jesus as much
as I want without any fear of violent
repercussions whatsoever
hey Jesus how you doing to me to pour
you some wine I am aware that in the
Muslim faith not believing in free
speech does not allow for the same
portrayals of Muhammad which is why in
these dramatizations I've gone to great
lengths to avoid doing so I am NOT
Mohammed okay firstly before we get to
their actual teaching let's start with
their personal lives though Jesus was
never married Muhammad seemingly
favorite wife was aja who according to
was around 6 though to be fair he only
consummated when she was 9 I have
puppies in back and in the spirit of
full disclosure Muhammad had many wives
as a matter of fact he had so many wives
here's a chart so while Jesus was
actually raising young adolescent girls
from the dead it seems that Muhammad was
a little more concerned with moving on
Jesus was actually pretty big on the
whole treating women with respect and
protecting them deal
Wow you're crossing some serious lines
he's got a lot of growing up to do oh
yeah
I'll tell you that right now but you the
floozy Oh like you're so perfect Carl I
can make one phone call
whereas Mohammed was not only involved
in the commanding of killing certain
women committed domestic violence
against his wife Aisha said that women
constituted a majority of hell but there
was actually a dame who was stoned to
death as per his individual orders now
regardless of his servitude Jesus never
demanded anything in return from these
women whereas Mohammed had quite a few
slaves and concubines please not
Mohammed tell me how I can please you
you can make me a sandwich like
yesterday many of these shall we call
them female properties he'd gained in
battle after having slaughtered their
fathers are you still here which leads
us to a key difference Jesus a servant
never fought a battle never owned a
slave and never killed the guy
not only did Mohammed do so but he
actually felt that it was his divine
calling to kill non-muslims and it
returned people who insulted him
you're a Brody you're dead which finally
brings us to the teachings of Jesus
versus Muhammad there are too many to
list here so let's go to the tale of the
tape Jesus taught to love your enemies
and teach your faith with gentleness and
respect Muhammad taught his followers to
kill convertors subjugate Christians and
Jews jesus said that God will judge
apostates Muhammad instructed his
followers to kill them Jesus taught
mercy the Quran teaches us punishment
over compassion
but if you're noticing a disturbing
trend here congratulations you're a
logical person but my challenge to you
this time is to go beyond reading a
chapter to start with the verses listed
in this video but try and read the New
Testament and the Quran in their
entirety and compare the two for
contrast see if you can spot some
differences that I've missed if so let
me know below I think the differences
are no better exemplified than Jesus's
last words having been tortured and
persecuted yet having never retaliated
on the cross asking God to forgive them
for they know not what they do
verses the last words of war waging
Mohammed having never been tortured or
persecuted to the same degree in which
he said may Allah curse the Jews and
Christians for they built the places of
worship at the graves of the prophets
the holiest of prophets and you're going
to make those your last words really
please what should I say lose that I'd
say that your peace and love will
transform the earth you know don't worry
about it
such throwing heads
[Music]
Oh anything that Mohammed what shall I
save you how do you feel about the Jews
[Music]